an out-of-control wildfire forcing
evacuations in yosemite national park
firefighters are battling severe
conditions on the ground and in the sky
with flames covering more than three
square miles and threatening the park's
famous giant sequoias some of the
largest trees in the world some of the
oldest living things on the planet john
the bigliotti is in yosemite he's made
his way jonathan good morning to you
what do we know
good morning to you tony the washburn
fire is burning in an area this morning
so remote it's even difficult for fire
crews to access it safely in just the
past day it's nearly doubled in size
threatening trees that have survived all
kinds of weather for thousands of years
more than 2 000 acres of flames paired
with blistering heat low humidity and
difficult terrain some 500 firefighters
are enduring brutal conditions while
battling the washburn fire still burning
out of control in the southern corner of
yosemite national park so obviously with
the higher temperatures that is going to
increase the fire behavior and intensity
of the fire the fire is so intense it's
creating its own weather system causing
updrafts powerful enough to launch
debris into the air when near miss with
an air attack tanker was caught on radio
a branch went right over the top of us
pretty good size so if we keep seeing
that we might have to knock it off i
don't want to take a chance of blocking
a window on an airplane or hurting an
aircraft for this the nearby community
of waona has been forced to evacuate
while hikers campers and vacationers
have been sent packing
hot shot crews are making their way
throughout the area tasked with
strategically planning containment lines
to save hundreds of iconic sequoias i'm
standing right in front of the grizzly
giant which is arguably one of the most
famous trees on earth and we've got a
sprinkler system set up around it and
we're trying to give it some you know
preventative first aid really
in utah record-breaking heat and high
winds are fueling massive wildfires in
the state the newest being the jacob
city fire whose flames spread to almost
six square miles with zero containment
meanwhile investigators have arrested
four men they say abandon a camp fire
that ignited the so-called halfway hill
fire in fillmore we need to be super
cautious and aware especially during
these red flag days that we have there's
going to be many more to come
and back here in california mega fires
over the past few years have killed off
an estimated 75 thousand sequoia trees
these are trees that were once believed
to be fire proof because of their thick
bark in some cases we're talking two
feet but all of that armor is not enough
to fend off the kinds of flames that
scientists say are being fueled by our
rapidly changing climate
vlad
jonathan thank you very much